poland's justice minister saying his
country thinks is being blackmailed by
the eu after the bloc threatened to
withdraw funds if some polish regions
failed to recognize lgbt rights
four districts have already backed down
then and revoked their policies that
discriminated against the gay community
earlier this month the european
commission told the regions that it
would withhold over 120 million euro if
the declarations remained in force
it comes two months after the bloc
initiated legal action against the
country as a whole for alleged
violations of lgbt rights but many are
apparently unhappy with this
intervention by the eu
[Music]
i believe that the european union should
not interfere with what's happening in
poland at all they should not act like
that especially if the city deserves
that money and should be given it
penalties and sanctions of this type
should not be imposed
i think the european union is right our
government is very homophobic i agree
with europe
the city authorities have the right to
not promote lgbt everyone has this right
the european union should find another
way
i'm not a fan of pro-lgbt zones but on
the other hand everyone has a ride to
their own life
on the part of the european union and it
is very unfair such things should not be
combined here is the man and here is the
money there are completely separate
matters i think nothing should be done
by force if there is no such need in
poland you do not have to force anything
so local governors justified their
u-turn saying they're not ready to be
accountable for the financial loss one
expert we heard from told us such an
approach by the eu to try to maintain
unity in the blocks of path to
dictatorship
every local power should act according
to the will
and have a lot
of degree of power especially in this
case especially in this case so uh you
know um i'm not entering to the subject
i'm not not talking about about lesbian
gay transgender and so on i'm talking
about a general view the general
principle that should be
well respected by the european union
unless the european union wants to
become itself a sort
of autocracy or dictatorship i think
it's a very democratic choice
i think that in former communist
countries like poland local
municipalities and local provinces so
local powers
they have power enough according to the
constitution to act according to their
will i think it is something which is
completely legitimate and should be
understood and should be allowed also
the central level
you